as descendants of apes there remains a
lingering ape in all of us that
continues to provoke many of our
behavioral and social traits in
particular one of the most apparent
characteristics that we continue to
share with our ape relatives is the
desire for the social position of alpha
male in the 8th world the alpha male is
everything he gets his pick of mates
ownership of territory and control over
his group all of which are not far from
the same desired interests of most men
and often women in the modern world so
what does it take to become an alpha in
the 8th world there are several factors
of play that determine who becomes the
Alpha they include things like size
loudness and the ability to dominate
others as unequals in the human world
becoming this sort of domineering alpha
involves most of the same factors we can
intimidate other humans into submission
through size intensity and force and if
we live with these behaviors we can
become this same sort of alpha but how
does the function of this position
compare in human world how do the
differences between humans and apes
weigh in on the value of such a
domineering behavioral archetype the
principle difference between human and
ape is the depth of our consciousness it
is still unclear as to what degree are
consciousness extends beyond our eight
relatives but the majority of
researchers and philosophers can agree
that we have a largely superior ability
to exhibit a conscious
that allows for self-awareness and
critical reflection we have passed a
threshold of mental complexity where we
can now think about thinking we can
consider our intentions and how our
actions may affect others we can take it
one step further and consider how others
reactions to our actions will make us
feel and think about ourselves and we
can employ reason empathy and morality
to act accordingly as a result even
though we may still have an ape in us
who hungers to be that of a domineering
alpha our higher human consciousness
caters to a different type of alpha for
example being an ape like alpha and
getting the pick of any woman may sound
appealing but it does not really help
with the pairing of the right man with
the right woman in the 8th world the
goal of the Alpha is to have sex and
reproduce with as many mates as possible
not to form intimate relationships but
in the human world we want relationships
we want to find partners who we can
exchange love with and help balance out
each other's lives
and in the context of friendships
behaving as a dominating and forceful
individual may acquire you yes men and
followers but not necessarily any true
friends because rarely does anyone want
to continue in a long-term friendship
comprised of dominance fear and
hierarchy
in a true friendship we want mutual
trust respect and affinity
therefore we must consider how our
primal desire to be a domineering alpha
affects our life and appropriately
regulated our ape self is constantly
lingering within us and it is not simple
or easy to overcome but by using our
faculty for higher consciousness to
understand our behaviors and their
effects we can construct and execute a
new refined concept of alpha a conscious
alpha we did not evolve over millions of
years to merely continue to perpetuate
the behaviors of our lesser ancestors
becoming a true human alpha involves
being able to adapt to the terms of the
current human condition to infuse
rationality self-awareness
and empathy into our behavior more
important than being big and loud and
forceful is being someone who can
exhibit compassion and reason we humans
function better off solidarity
compassion and intellect and so it is
these qualities that we must attend to
if we wish to truly be a prevailing
human thank you for watching if you
found enjoyment and value in this video
please give it a thumbs up share your
thoughts in the comments below and if
you are not already be sure to subscribe
to our channel we are constantly coming
out with new videos to help you
experience life with clarity and Wonder